welcome back to another Q&A episode of
the stronger by science podcast in
today's episode Greg and I field
questions about how much time
powerlifter should spend training for
hypertrophy how frequently to bulk
optimal rest periods for strength and
hypertrophy whether or not you need to
be doing deadlifts or deadlift
variations for physique related goals
and much more on a related note we
recently rolled out a new feature on the
stronger by science website we have
extracted clips from all of our Q&A
episodes and organized them by topic so
now you can quickly find in-depth
answers to your training and nutrition
related questions to check it out head
over to stronger by science comm /q a if
you'd like to submit new questions for a
future Q&A episode you can do that by
going to tiny CC slash SBS QA as always
thank you for listening and enjoy the
episode
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast this is your
host Eric Trexler and today I've got a
special guest host temporary guest host
named Greg knuckles now before we get
into the questions today interesting
thing happened this morning I was
watching television there's a program
called College GameDay they preview all
of the forthcoming college football
games for the day and in this week's
episode they did a special showcase on
Boyd Eppley and it was a nice little
history lesson about strength and
conditioning obviously our audience has
a keen interest in strength and
conditioning sport performance
weightlifting and so it was a cool
little like I said a little historical
look at how it all got started so little
known story again my source is that show
so credit where credit's due for the
longest time people thought if you lift
weights you get bulky you get slow you
can't perform sport at a high level the
Nebraska college football team was
playing Oklahoma in 1969 they got beat
they got beat bad and they didn't feel
good about it and one of their coaches
said we should go hire this guy who says
he can make us better through lifting
weights the head coach was pretty
hesitant but they went ahead and made
the hire and and that the person they
hired was Boyd Eppley so he was the
first paid strength coach in college
history went on to be a co-founder of
the NSC a national strength and
conditioning Association and like I said
the head coach was skeptical at first so
their weight room was smaller than a
three car garage basically had no
equipment and a Boyd's salary was four
dollars a day and his sat his staff was
not paid for their time the next year
they played Oklahoma again had a huge
win and people started to take notice of
what Nebraska was doing differently at
that point strength coaches kind of took
off and became a trend in college
football and the rest is history so you
know these college football strength
coaching jobs these days you'll see guys
making I mean well over what like
$500,000 a year it's kind of like the
premier place to do strength and
conditioning is high level college
football and you
if you've ever wondered why I mean it
was pretty much at least in the States
pretty much where it got started yeah in
if you're wondering about inflation rate
cuz you know four dollars a day in 1969
that was a while ago that was prior to
the high inflation of the 1970s even
accounting for inflation assuming he was
coaching 365 days a year which i think
is probably a pretty big assumption
that's still less than 10 grand a year
so like four dollars in 1969 would be
about 27 bucks today you look at I mean
God I don't know what
Nebraska's strength coach makes now but
there's no way it's less than like 300
grand right yeah we Jamie pull that up
for us yeah whoo Jamie I think I learned
from reddit is a male that is something
we got wrong in a prior episode still
have not ever listened to a Joe Rogan
podcast yeah but a lot of people come to
us for their I think a lot of people
view us as journalists first and
foremost so when we get it wrong god I
hope that when we get it wrong we get
back on we make the correction so Jamie
apparently a male yes so as of this year
the head strength coach of Nebraska
makes $400,000 a year
yeah and that that's which is as much as
the president I believe but the question
is who does more important work well
considering Nebraska's record this year
that's a good point yeah okay let's get
into some more pertinent questions here
we've got two questions for Gregg that
are very related so these come from oh
boy the first one is from joltin Rast it
seems right so Gregg and a good
powerlifting program how much times
slash volume should be spent on
hypertrophy work and how should this
change based on training experience and
whether it's the on season or the
offseason now the second question that's
related is from Zack he says I want to
look jacked how do I know if I am strong
enough to be messing around with
bodybuilding style training annex
to rework the the general gist of the
question being when am I ready to
graduate from focusing on you know
strict strength training with the
compound lifts and start branching out
into doing more bodybuilding type
accessories yes so my opinion for both
of these is kind of as your training
career training career progresses as a
power lifter you probably need to do
gradually less hypertrophy work and then
also as you're getting closer to a meet
you probably need to do less hypertrophy
work so in the case of Zacks question it
sounds like he probably hasn't been
training all that long and isn't all
that strong yet so it doesn't know if he
should be doing hypertrophy work yet or
just purely focusing on strength in his
case I think it's the opposite I think
if anything he should be focused on
hypertrophy work trying to fill out his
frame and then strength should follow
from that or at least with a larger base
of muscularity it will then be easier to
build more strength and so yeah I mean
it also it also depends on the
individual and what their goals are you
know some people are training in a
powerlifting style just to hit the
biggest squat bench deadlift they can or
the highest Wilke score or the most IPF
points possible you know other people
want to be stronger but they also have
aesthetic goals as well and if they
could you know let's say total 1500
pounds at 181 and be really competitive
or total 1500 pounds at 198 but just
look more jacked butts be less
competitive in the process they'd
probably go with looking more jacked
even if that makes them less competitive
so I mean like obviously the individuals
goals factored in here as well so if
like being strong and also jacked is
just a big motivator for you do more
hypertrophy work if you're someone who's
just main goal is strength and
optimizing long term strength
development then I kind of revert to my
original answer
you know first few months in the gym
just practice the movements get your
motor patterns down you will
naturally grow from exposing your body
to a new stimulus then after that period
probably still not a bad idea to keep
some heavy work in your training but
then for you know the next couple of
years you're probably gonna get the most
bang for your buck in the long term just
by working on filling out your frame
doing more hypertrophy work then once
you've kind of settled into the weight
class that seems like it's going to be
appropriate for you in the long term or
at least the next few years then and
also like I mean hypertrophy slows down
over time if you're someone who mainly
competes in bodybuilding and you've been
at it for 10 years and it takes you
three years of training to put on three
solid pounds of muscle like that's still
literally your entire sport it makes
sense to make that investment if you're
a power lifter and it's like okay I'm
gonna have to put the heavier may be
slightly lower volume higher intensity
strength work on the back burner for
three years to really dedicate myself
type hurt free work to put two or three
pounds of muscle on my frame like at
that point the the trade-off doesn't
make much sense so you know I think you
should kind of at least right off the
bat get all of the hypertrophy that's
going to come easily to you and then
start focusing more specifically on
strength and then second part of that
question depending if it's on or
offseason it's gonna kind of depend on
how your meats are spaced out to kind of
determine whether you do have a true
offseason or not but you know assuming
you do have a true offseason if you are
especially currently trying to fill out
a weight class better or move up a
weight class that's your time to do
hypertrophy work probably not a good
idea to you know be doing your sets of
10 to 15 or whatever four weeks out from
a meet so yeah newer lifters overall
even if your focus is strength long term
more hypertrophy work is probably going
to be who view and then as you get
closer to a meet and as training status
increases and you you know find what
weight class is probably going to be
your home for the next few years
more specific strength work is is
probably going to be the way to go
another aspect of the on season off
season part of the question is you know
sometimes on the off season you might
just need to give yourself a little
break like you know I had trained like
pretty specific powerlifting type stuff
at certain stretches of time in my
lifting career and powerlifting stuff's
different man like bodybuilding has its
challenges particularly on the diet side
but I remember when I first got into
powerlifting type training that was
specific a lot of the big three hard and
heavy a lot of sets and I felt like I
got hit by a bus like honestly I mean
well I mean it's probably just because
you were very much habituated to
something else right because for me if I
train like that it's normal and I feel
fine but if I went to like if I went to
the gym today and squatted I don't know
like three fairly challenging sets of
ten to twelve reps I would be destroyed
tomorrow because that's not the type of
training I am at all habituated to yeah
even with your joints like you don't
notice less wear and tear on your joints
when you do like some lighter loads for
heavier for higher reps for me it feels
like more wear and tear on my joints
like everything just birds constantly
for weeks
yeah for whatever reason my joints
really love heavy like singles doubles
triples but when I dropped the weight
and just do more reps in in I'm not
saying that that's a generalizable thing
I think it's likely to be different for
a lot of people but yeah for me just as
the sheer number of reps I do climbs up
unless it's with the really really light
loads so you know if I go if I go out on
the road right now and do a set of like
a hundred body weight walking lunges
that'll be fine
but like fairly challenging sets of 10
plus squats multiple sets like no my
knees very rarely feel creaky but that
will make my knees feel creaky so I mean
I think it just varies person to person
yeah yeah because my experience has been
completely the opposite but every now
and then I'll have a client who's mostly
strength focused and there's just the
general wear and tear of hard and heavy
training for a long time or just the
staleness of being on a similar strength
focused program for week after week
after week after week sometimes there
i've found some benefit to saying let's
just for the next six weeks let's just
do like a very bodybuilding focus t25
had is for well for this question and
really a lot of the questions we answer
there's kind of like a scientifically
correct or like a quote-unquote
theoretically optimal answer to the
question and then there's also just the
practical answer to the question and
really i mean i think if you are
consistent with your training and
training relatively hard for 10-15 years
you're gonna get pretty big you're gonna
get pretty strong so you know if you're
someone who does have strength goals but
you really just don't like doing
specific powerlifting training for
months on in do less of it
in the short to moderate term that's
probably going to be a little bit less
efficient for strength gains especially
if you've been in the game for four
years at this point but like that's fine
or if you're someone who's who's mostly
trying to get big but you just really
like heavy strength focus training
you're probably gonna put on muscle a
little bit slower than you would if you
did more focused hypertrophy work but
you know stick with it for years and you
are going to put muscle on your frame so
if if doing something that is
theoretically better runs the risk of
harming adherence and harming
consistency like ultimately if you just
gravitate to the style of training you
enjoy more you will you know get the
vast majority of the benefits you would
have gotten may take a little bit longer
but
it still gets you two to virtually the
same place over time all right
so question here for Trek's from john
ship there's a lot of balking discussion
on recent shows most of it focused on
the size of the caloric surplus I'd be
interested in hearing about practical
recommendations regarding the frequency
of bulks and cuts how often is common
and is there a ceiling where it's no
longer effective in terms of strength or
even harmful over over a given time
period
I assume there to stay in a bulk yeah so
we've talked a little bit about this in
the context of mini cuts I think you
know that idea of oscillating between
bulking and cutting cycles and and how
frequently is too frequently so this is
a look at a similar question but from
the opposite perspective so looking at
essentially how often people should bulk
and if there's some diminishing returns
there so first of all I would push back
a little bit against the idea of using
bulking as a categorical variable
meaning you are either either bulking or
not bulking I think it makes a lot more
sense to say how big is the surplus
because you can't really separate the
duration of the bulk from the magnitude
of the bulk if that makes sense so you
know a bulk theoretically could be any
particular time period may be a day when
your energy intake exceeds your
expenditure but realistically we're
talking about how frequently how long
and how large of a magnitude should have
bulk be so that's the first thing to
keep in mind is that obviously if you're
going really intense with the magnitude
of the bulk and you have a huge enters
energy surplus and that bulk should be
shorter in duration and those types of
bulks bulks because they come with a
high risk of fat gain they should
probably be done fairly rarely now if
you're doing a much more modest approach
to bulking then that should last longer
because the the day to day surplus is
smaller and those can probably be
implemented
either for longer durations of time or
more frequently throughout the year
because the the short-term risk of
gaining a lot of fat mass it would be
minimized but at the heart of this
question I think there's two questions
you have to ask yourself before you kind
of make a plan for bulking and the two
questions are first of all where are you
going and second of all when do you need
to get there so exactly how big do you
wish to get and do we have a specific
timeframe for achieving that that goal
because the simplest approach would be
yobbo you only bulk once you basically
start your lifting career you bulk up
until you have all the lean mass you'd
ever want then you cut to the body fat
you'd prefer to maintain long term and
now you're done you've got your dream
physique you're in maintenance mode you
you're you're golden you've got what you
want that would be the theoretically
simplest approach but nobody's going to
be happy with that because that takes
some very serious long-term investment
you have to sacrifice a lot of
short-term goals and basically say I'm
gonna start this process and maybe in
five to six years I'm gonna be stoked
with what I've got at the end now the
more likely approach is your first bulk
that you do your first dedicated bulk
the goal should be to bulk to the
minimum lean body mass that you'd be
happy with like this isn't my all-time
dream goal for lean body mass but this
is an amount of lean mass that I'd be
very comfortable maintaining in the
short term and then building from there
and in and that's assuming it's a
somewhat reasonable number Carine if
you're starting with sixty kilos of lean
body mass and you're like a minimum I'd
really be happy with is like ninety then
you you might be in for some tough
sledding right yeah that what normally
happens is I'll have someone who comes
to me as a potential client and they say
I want to have way more muscle and I
also want to be leaner should I bulk
first or cut first and what I usually
tell them is if we cut now from where
you're at
because you're unhappy with the amount
of lean mass you have in your mind
you're thinking well we'll finish the
cut and we'll be ripped and then we'll
start adding lean mass but usually what
happens is you cut and then you say I'm
not ripped I'm skinny and I'm very
unhappy
so like usually people who do the cut
first route are very unhappy at the end
of that kind yeah they they have an idea
in mind like I'm gonna look like peak
Bruce Lee and they just end up looking
like the mechanic yeah exactly yeah yeah
so yeah they want to be a Batman
Christian Bale but they are the mechanic
Christian Bale oh man but no so talk
about insane body transformations though
because he went from one of the Batman
films to the mechanic to another Batman
film to the fighter where he was
similarly you know anemic to another
Batman film like his body weight was
fluctuating like I think about 80 pounds
per film which is ridiculous yeah anyway
carry on when I'm just I'm just very
impressed by how how good Christian Bale
was at manipulating his body comp didn't
he also play like a very frumpy dick
chaney he that was after the fact he
also played that still a transformation
I think he got pretty it was he also
played a pretty overweight character on
American hustle I'm pretty sure yeah
those are the the transformations I love
is when someone just completely
intentionally lets themselves go for a
role and you're like nice the one people
forget about and I'm blanking on the
name of the film is Stallone did that
one time to like people always think of
Stallone as you know the guy who's 70
years old and has been in shape
constantly for the last 50 years but at
one point I think sometime in the
mid-2000s he he played a film where he
was just like a local cop or something
like that and yeah he he had a hard time
acting the role because like the guy was
supposed to feel kind of like dumpy and
down on his luck but like you know he's
still Stallone
you can throw baggy clothes on him but
he's still Sylvester Stallone and he
found that to play the role he actually
had to you know get out of shape for the
first time in his entire adult life and
that let him act the role and then you
know six months later he's [ __ ] ripped
again yeah so basically what I'm getting
at is I don't really look at bulking as
like I don't think there's a lot of
inherent utility in telling someone how
frequently to bulk
i I think that bulks should be
intentional and they should have
specific endpoints in mind and so what
that means is instead of saying I'm
going to do a six-month bulk every two
years or something like that when you
approach your next bulk it should be
because right now you are maintaining
less lean mass than you want and so you
want to change that and what you would
do is say okay well I want to add this
many pounds of lean mass I'm comfortable
with this much fat gain in the process
and I'd like to achieve it by this
endpoint and so that's how you basically
determine how big your your surplus
should be and how long it's going to
take to get there so the idea of looking
at as you know bulking is a categorical
variable that you either
you're either bulking or not bulking I
don't know if that's a particularly
nuanced way to envision it and more
importantly the how frequently you do it
is really not how frequently really
comes down to how comfortable you are
with your current amount of lean mass so
like I said the most straightforward way
to do it is just say I'm gonna build all
the lean mass I'd ever want and then
I'll cut and be shredded and then I'll
be happy forever but what we find in a
lifting career is goals shift and so you
you always thought that you wanted to
you know be 180 pounds and you'd be
thrilled and then you get there and
you're there for a while then you say
turns out I'd rather be 200 pounds and
then it's time to bulk again so I would
deter people from using kind of a
calendar to determine their cut cut in
bulk cycles and rather make sure that
those cuts and bulks are specifically
tailored to go
and are done intentionally with very
specific end points in mind I would say
this to try to make it less theoretical
and more actionable sometimes I see
people who ball can cut way too
frequently so that's definitely anything
that can happen and so what they'll do
is they'll say I'm gonna bulk and then
they gain any amount of fat and they say
too much I'm gonna cut and then they you
know cut and they say I wish I was
bigger and then they bulk and cut in
bulk and cut I would say if you're gonna
bulk you should plan it out such that
you're never bulking for less than at
the absolute bare minimum a month at a
time because you really do have to be
realistic about how rapidly you could
even potentially hope to add an
appreciable amount of muscle tissue I
would say even if you're somebody who
just wants a little tiny bump in their
lean mass and you don't want to go you
know you're not trying to add really
substantial amounts of lean mass at
least give yourself a month set your
surplus accordingly but I feel like all
too often you see people who are just
constantly going back and forth between
bulks and cuts not because they're happy
with how it's going but because once
they devote time and attention to one
goal they realize that they prefer the
other goal instead it's kind of like the
grass is always greener on the other
side they start putting on some muscle
and they're like oh no I want to be
shredded instead so at least dedicate
yourself if you're going to do a bulk
minimum one month in duration for almost
all contexts I rarely make blanket
statements like that but if you set out
there for a two-week bulk I don't know
what you're gonna accomplish yeah I mean
if you do put on lean mass it's glycogen
and water right so the second part is is
there a ceiling where it's no longer
effective or even harmful over a given
time period
absolutely yeah I mean so there will be
some people who are eating in a surplus
but they are for whatever reason not not
gaining the good kind of tissue like you
want and so that that would be a place
where it's no longer effective
theoretically and I mean if if you're in
a bulk meaning
you're eating a surplus and you're not
gaining strength and not gaining muscle
then that would be a net negative thing
in most contexts now you could be
somebody who's way too lean and could
use some additional fat so that that
could still potentially there could be
some people who it makes sense to do
that but generally speaking if you find
yourself in a position where you don't
want to gain fat you're eating in a
surplus but you're not getting bigger or
stronger then that would mean that you
probably need to do some structural
changes to what you're doing so really
take a close look at your training and
figure out am I actually stimulating
muscle growth effectively on the
training side of the equation rather
than the eating side some people might
just be at the limit of how far they're
willing to go in terms of putting on
lean mass I mean that's gonna be a small
percentage of the people listening to
this but not necessarily though because
that doesn't mean your genetics ceiling
it just means like basically you you run
into a spot where there are no longer
things you're willing to do to make the
qualitative and quantitative changes to
your approach to actually make
significant increases from there so like
if you're like okay well this is as far
as I'm gonna get training four days a
week for about an hour at a time and I'm
not willing to do more than that and I'm
not willing to restructure my training
you're pretty much where you're gonna be
with what you're willing to do so
absolutely you can get to a point when
you're bulking where it no longer makes
sense you're no longer increasing
strength or size we talked about this in
the past Greg there are times where
you're increasing strength but not
muscle that happens with lifters so
that's why I say you know there could be
some people who even though they're not
putting on muscle anymore it still makes
sense because they're still getting
stronger on that bulk for some reason
like we've talked about it before we
don't know the exact reason maybe it has
to do with leverages we don't know we've
talked about it vexes us but for some
people putting on a little bit of fat
does seem to boost their total a little
bit but in any case yeah absolutely
there's a limit where it no longer is
productive and in some cases can be
counterproductive because you're not
getting more muscular you're not getting
stronger and theoretically certain
indicators of your cardio metabolic
health might be
taken a little a little hit so an
interesting note
like I said we're good fair and balanced
journalists here we talked about dreamer
bulks in the past on an episode and we
got the origin wrong I got the origin
wrong apparently I I didn't know it
either yeah apparently the word dreamer
bulk I always assumed it was because
you're under this whimsical idea that
you're like oh yeah this is a really
good bulk but really you're dreaming
right like it's not but but it turns out
that it is the confluence and
intertwining of two of the better memes
that ever came out of bodybuilding.com
yes oh so the purse I guess there was a
person who's bodybuilding.com name was
dreamer right and they embarked on a not
a really audacious fall they dared to go
where no bulker had gone before and just
a small proportion of the weight gained
was lean mass is the general consensus I
think that's very fair to say what's the
other part what's the other meme that is
the individual from whom the Frog tech
names came which was so so that that's
an old-school meme if you've if you've
only been in you know the the online
resistance training space for I would
say probably fewer than five years you
may have not seen the the Frog Tech
memes but they were they were spicy back
in the day it may be worth googling yeah
those pictures were hilarious okay so
moving on oh and one other thing I'd
like to clarify the Stallone movie was
called Copland released I believe in
1997 so if you want to see the one time
in his life Sylvester Stallone wasn't
shredded just Google Sylvester Stallone
Copland did you see the movie No
so also in in the interest of full
disclosure I only know about this
because I saw someone post about it on
Facebook and I believe it was Brian cron
so shout outs to Brian no I have I have
not seen the film I am not by any means
a Stallone aficionado fair enough
alright so moving on we've got again two
similar questions that we kind of lump
together here Aiden has a question Aiden
says I've noticed that my lifts have
gotten stronger as my lists have gotten
stronger my rest periods are becoming
longer what's the mechanism behind that
what can I do to help mitigate it the
second question is from Jared means and
the question is what does the literature
say about rest time between sets for
maximizing hypertrophy versus maximizing
strength is it possible to take too much
or too little time between sets okay so
to start with Aiden this question yeah
there's a pretty straightforward
mechanism by which you would probably
just naturally gravitate to longer rest
intervals as you get stronger and that
is because the caloric cost and
therefore the oxygen cost of exercise
roughly scales with work rate work here
being the physics definition so you know
you have a distance component a time
component and a force component if you
know a set of ten takes roughly the same
amount of time or you know just the
total I guess the time component isn't
that important because that's gonna
affect the rate but not necessarily the
total caloric cost anyway but assuming
your range of motion doesn't
dramatically change you're doing the
same number of reps but you're doing it
with 50% more weight the total oxygen
cost of that set is going to be about 50
percent higher and so you know if you
think about it similarly to running if
you run 200 meters pretty leisurely in a
minute that's gonna be perfectly fine
unless you're an elite four hundred
meter runner if you run 400 meters in
the same minute that's going to be very
very tough it's the exact same thing
you're covering twice as much distance
your work rate has doubled the cooler
cost and oxygen cost have doubled you're
going to be a lot more tired from and
it's going to take you longer to recover
from that exertion so it's the exact
same thing with lifting weights as long
as range motion doesn't change weight on
the bar goes up oxygen cost goes up
takes longer to recover from it's just
generally harder so yeah I mean that
makes all the sense in the world you can
you can see this in in any gym you go to
where there's a range of people kind of
stratified by strength if you see
someone it's you know maybe they've been
lifting for six months they kind of have
their major motor patterns down but
they're by no means strong yet and you
see them do a really really hard set of
10 squats so you know maybe they're 10
rep max squat is 200 pounds and you see
them you know do do the hardest set of
10 they've ever done with 200 pounds
they barely grind out the last rep
they're gonna be tired afterwards
certainly their muscles are going to be
pumped they're gonna be breathing hard
two or three minutes later they're gonna
be fine if on the other hand you see
someone do a similarly challenging set
of 10 squats with 600 pounds even if
they're in you know decent shape maybe
they also do some cardio outside the gym
they're not just like completely out of
shape but they do a set of 10 squats at
600 pounds and you know it's a similarly
challenging set they're gonna be wrecked
for 10 minutes just because that's
that's an absurdly anaerobically taxing
effort they just did so man I I did the
math on this one time I had to make some
extrapolation so there was a study by
Brown and colleagues in 1994 that
calculated the oxygen cost of deadlifts
and then that was kind of carried
forward in an Escamilla study I believe
in 2001 looking at the oxygen cost of
sumo and convinced
deadlifts so if we make some assumptions
like the oxygen cost of squatting being
similar to to deadlifts at least on like
a per range-of-motion basis I think I
calculated one time that the total
oxygen cost of a set of 10 squats was
600 pounds was like somewhere in the
neighborhood of sprinting about 600
meters give or take
difference being unless you're in
incredibly good shape sprinting 600
meters is probably gonna take a minute
and a half or more and for most lifters
it's probably gonna take two minutes or
more on the other hand you know you
knock out that set of ten squats maybe
in a minute tops if you're if you're
really getting after the first couple of
reps maybe 30 45 seconds so you know
you're talking about the similar caloric
cost to running almost half a mile but
you're doing it in under a minute
and yeah that's you're gonna take a
while to recover from that
just the sheer anaerobic stress you put
yourself under is absolutely insane at
that point if you have never done a
Wingate test on one hand I'd recommend
you never do a Wingate test they're
[ __ ] terrible on the other hand I
would recommend you do a Wingate test if
you're not a super strong person so you
can understand what it's like for a
super strong person to do a high rep set
of like squats or deadlifts because
Wingate test is essentially in an
aerobic test involving a bike
mechanically braked bike where you
sprint as hard as possible for 30
seconds and everyone is dead at the end
of a Wingate test that is that is a
universal thing and so one one key
consideration people are thinking oh a
bike sprint for 30 seconds that works
there's a loaded component right right
so like I said it's a mechanically brake
bike you can't just you know hop on a
fan bike
your local CrossFit box or something and
approximated your you're gonna need a
cycle ergometer to pull it off but
anyway like the wind guy tests are
terrible for everyone no matter how good
of shape you're in you feel awful
after a Wingate test and if you're not a
pretty strong person doing a Wingate
test is probably the only way you can
really get an idea of how hard high rep
training is for really strong people
because that's the only way you're gonna
be able to induce like a similar level
of anaerobic stress for yourself so
anyway very long way of answering the
answering Ayden's question yes it makes
sense you're gonna have to rest longer
as you get stronger just because the
oxygen cost of exercise goes up is
weight on the bar goes up assuming you
know total displacement is the same so
yeah that makes all the sense in the
world quick addition on the topic of
Wingate so windgates
even people that are really legit strong
fit people a Wingate will wreck you for
like minutes after you've done it like I
mean I think it probably wrecks you more
if you're in better shape cuz like if
your total anaerobic capacity is higher
you can simply induce more anaerobic
stress than you would be if you were in
worse shape yeah in any case like a lot
of times you'll you'll be in like an
exercise science lab and some tough guy
goes oh yeah I got this but you will be
wrecked for like minutes afterward and
the reason I bring that up if you ever
see a study where they do a repeated
Wingate test and you see that these poor
bastards did like four Wingate's over
like a four-minute span or something
yeah it is frankly unethical
I mean ie if it weren't for the fact
that there was consent given that very
well may violate the Eighth Amendment
yeah it's like that that's the cruel and
unusual punishment one right yeah yeah
when you look at it at a test protocol
and you're like so our subjects did for
windgates and you're like what it's it's
easy to look over if you don't know what
a Windgate is so I could be wrong about
this
so full disclosure here I don't watch
hockey I know
exceedingly little about it I went to my
first live hockey game last week there's
a lot of fun I may go back but anyway I
don't know anything about the sport but
someone told me that for the hockey
combine you know much like the NFL or
NBA combine they have a combine for the
hockey draft and one of the aspects of
that is repeated Wingate tests I believe
it's just two with maybe like a three or
five minute rest and they want to see
how much performance well one just how
good performances and the first one and
then two how much it drops off to the
second one but yeah I mean it I don't
know if the hockey combine is televised
the same way the NFL Combine is but if
it is you should try to find video of it
I guarantee you all of those guys are
gonna walk away from their second of the
two Wingate tests as if they're drunk
and nearing death because it's terrible
for sure okay so that's Aiden's question
Jarrod's was very similar also asking
about rest intervals asking what does
the literature say about rest times to
maximize hypertrophy versus maximizing
strength so it's difficult to split out
hypertrophy and strength here just
because there aren't that many well
controlled studies that have looked at
either of these two questions and I
think all of the ones that do exist
measured both hypertrophy and strength
intended to have similar results and
also don't use exceptionally well
trained lifters so I could very well see
the the answer being different for in
untrained lifter versus you know someone
who's who's already a pretty high level
lifter but anyway with those caveats out
of the way there is I think the general
belief I think that's the correct way to
word it here but a general belief in the
like quote unquote evidence-based
fitness community that longer rest
intervals are superior for both
hypertrophy and strength that kind of
runs counter to the
the at least like old-school bro belief
and I actually think the belief that
still published in the NSC a and ACSM
guidelines if not they were at least
like in the prior version of the
guidelines that ideal for hypertrophy at
least was shorter rest intervals I
believe 60 to 90 seconds so anyway the
the reason that I think a lot of people
in the again quote-unquote
evidence-based fitness community believe
that longer rest intervals are superior
is Brad Schoenfeld did a study a couple
years ago comparing if memory serves 60
versus 150 seconds of rest per set but
it regardless it was like a short versus
a long rest interval and the short
wasn't crazy short it wasn't like 15
seconds okay so it was one minute versus
three minutes I pulled it up and so in
that study the group with the longer
rest intervals the three minute rest
intervals did get better results I
believe in both hypertrophy and strength
and so like I love Brad he does good
research one and so this isn't a knock
on Brad at all it's it's more a knock of
people who consume science mostly via
Facebook or Twitter when someone kind of
within our community publishes a study a
lot of people just take that as gospel
and don't really look to see what other
research has been published in the area
perhaps by researchers who aren't as
well known and prolific on social media
so I absolutely don't think there's
anything wrong with Brad's study but I
think that's kind of the driving force
behind people just assuming that longer
rest intervals are you know better for
everyone across the board but there is
other research in the area so there was
another study by beresch very similar to
to Brad's study and also had very
similar results longer rest intervals
were better
short and her rest intervals however
there was also a study by Villanueva it
used older subjects but it also tested
long versus short rest intervals and in
that study the shorter rest intervals
produced I know for sure more
hypertrophy I think larger strength
gains as well but you know I'm not
rereading a dozen studies before
recording this podcast but basically
Schoenfeld and beresch better with
longer rest intervals villanueva better
with shorter rest intervals there was a
study by Fink testing high reps with
short rest intervals against moderate
reps with longer rest intervals and it
found more hypertrophy with the high
reps short rest intervals and based on
what we know about hyper treated with
different rest different rep ranges the
Fink study was testing sets of 20
against sets of eight theoretically in a
vacuum those should produce similar
hypertrophy and so you know that also
leaned in favor of shorter rest
intervals being better and then another
study by Fink and colleagues tested
short and long rest intervals thirty
seconds versus one hundred and fifty
seconds and found similar hypertrophy in
both conditions so essentially you know
we have five studies in this body of
literature to lean in favor of longer
Esther intervals to lean in favor of
shorter and then ones just kind of a
toss-up so I'm at least as far as
hypertrophy goes for like untrained or
moderately trained lifters I'm pretty
agnostic from a hypertrophy perspective
I'm not convinced of like the old school
idea that shorter rest intervals are
better I'm also not convinced of I think
what is the the more common current
orthodoxy that longer Esther intervals
are better I think that that's kind of
still an open question when it comes to
hypertrophy and I would say the same
thing about strength for again untrained
and moderately trained lifters what I
will say though is that just based on my
variants both as a reasonably strong
person myself from training with a lot
of strong people and coaching a lot of
pretty strong people is I do think that
short rest intervals can absolutely
become counterproductive with pretty
well trained pretty strong folks if your
main goal is strength development mostly
just because like kind of building on
the answer to Ayden's previous question
if you're pretty strong unless you're
just doing super low rep sets each set
is going to have a high enough oxygen
cost that if you want to perform you
know even comparably well in your next
set it's gonna take a reasonably long
period of time to recover that may not
matter all that much for hypertrophy
because ultimately you know you're
trying to get enough tension on the
muscle you're probably trying to induce
some metabolic stress if you're not
fully recovered from the previous set it
may not make a tremendously big
difference but I do think that your
actual performance in the gym does
matter considerably for strength
development and your performance is just
going to fall off precipitously set to
set to set if you're reasonably strong
and you keep your rest intervals really
short so anyway pretty agnostic when it
comes to hypertrophy for strength
I do think longer rest intervals tend to
be better and if I was just putting some
numbers on that for upper body exercise
or kind of single joint exercise for any
muscle group I'd say minimum of about 90
90 seconds to two minutes and probably
around three minutes of rest per set and
if you're pretty strong and you're doing
compound lower body training I'd say
probably five ish minutes of rest
between sets is what I'd recommend and
if you're quite strong in especially
doing moderate to higher reps maybe even
longer than five minutes again if your
main goal here strength development
those are those are my opinions both
kind of from the literature and just my
own experience on the matter
I've got similar guidelines from
clients that I coach so like one aspect
is you know what is the the research say
is most optimal and then another another
consideration is just the practical
application and so when I'm putting
together a program for a client I want
to make sure we're getting the training
volume in that we need and making sure
that we're able to keep up with the
intensity that's prescribed but at the
same time we don't want to be in the gym
for like three hours a day because we
also are like an accountant right like
you know like I like it's got there's
got to be a trade-off of like to me the
practical question is how much rest do I
need to make sure this that it
facilitates me being able to do the next
set effectively without turning my
workout into like a two and a half hour
ordeal and so a lot of times I'll tell
my clients like take as much time as you
need if you find that you're needing an
exceptionally long amount of time then
we're probably doing too much or too
heavy right yeah but generally speaking
I say you're doing like an isolation
exercise hypertrophy kind of stuff you
know lateral raises with dumbbells take
a minute you know if a minute two
minutes maybe right but if you need more
than two minutes to recover from
dumbbell lateral raises we got it we got
a problem going on you know and like you
you probably need to hop on the
elliptical right yeah yeah but then when
it comes to we're doing our main primary
compound for the day our benching or
squatting our dead lifting take three
minutes if you need five minutes take
five but but definitely it depends on
with what exercise we're performing
there for sure and another thing I would
say is if time becomes a concern you
feel free to do like feel free to do
super sets that make sense so the the
two kinds of super sets that tend to be
used in the literature are agonist super
sets so you know let's say bench press
and dumbbell flyes and antagonist super
sets so for example like bench press and
barbell rows there are plenty of other
options out there and I think generally
I would reckon
another option especially if you're
doing full body training so for example
if you're doing bench and deadlift in
the same workout and you're also gonna
do some tricep work for your bench and
you're also gonna do some hamstring work
for your deadlift what I recommend is
doing something like start your workout
with deadlifts and tricep extensions and
then moving on to bench and hamstring
curls that could potentially be
problematic if it's like your heaviest
bench session of the week and you are
like specifically benching for strength
development and you know maybe the
tricep pre fatigue could negatively
affect your benchpress performance but
you know then you could just kind of
shuffle accessories around through the
week where you know if you were going to
do bicep stuff on another day or like
rear delt stuff on another day you could
just sub out your tricep work on that
day with your bicep or rear delt work on
the other day and then have a workout
where it's like you know deadlift and
bicep curls superset it one sounds like
a [ __ ] gnarly superset - that
shouldn't negatively affect your
subsequent bench training and then move
on and do bench and hamstring curls you
know doing bicep curls between sets of
deadlifts should not make it take a
substantially longer to recover between
sets of deadlifts but it still lets you
get that work in that you otherwise
would just have to do at the end and
tack time onto your to your training and
same thing with the hamstring curls that
shouldn't negatively affect your ability
to recover between sets of bench but you
know those are two exercises you can
then do together instead of having to
tack something else onto the end of your
workout so you know a setup like that
could still allow you to rest adequately
between sets of deadlifts and between
sets of benchpress still get the same
amount of work in and just make things a
little bit more efficient I personally
don't like doing that
but I also don't have a problem with
being in the gym for two and a half
three hours so yeah if the the amount of
time you do train
and have to Train is a big concern for
you
supersets or your friend and just try to
make those super sets make sense such
that you know you're mostly super
setting a compound lift with a single
joint lift and the single joint lift
you're doing isn't going to affect the
compound lift you're currently doing or
important compound lifts that are going
to come later in your workout alright so
next question we have for treks is from
Matt I'm just seeing this question now
okay so Matt asks rank these sports in
order of difficulty in competitiveness
okay near the sports mins natural
bodybuilding men's natural classic
physique baseball basketball and
football I'm assuming football here is
American football but maybe he also
means soccer yeah I'm going with the
assumption that we're talking American
football there and this is an easy one
so I'm just gonna be quick baseball
number five you could very comfortably
eat three hotdogs and drink a beer while
playing a baseball game so number five
basketball number four for a couple
reasons first of all I wrestled and the
in America those happen during the same
season so you can't do both so I
obviously have a bias toward wrestling
and away from basketball the other thing
is basketball does not have specific
rules that have been made to determine
if someone was intentionally trying to
give you brain damage which brings me to
number three which is football very
difficult sport people are trying to
harm you in very serious ways but the
stakes aren't that high which leads me
to number one and two high stakes high
level of talent enormous talent pool
classic physique and natural
bodybuilding but which one is number one
number one is bodybuilding the main
reason that natural bodybuilding just
edges out classic physique for the
number one spot is because with classic
physique you don't necessarily have to
hit yourself quite as much as you get
ready for stage you got to get those
last couple pounds off to do the
bodybuilding class and those last couple
pounds are the absolute worst you can
put on the
the briefs for classic bodybuilding not
have shredded glutes and still feel like
a human being that is an almost edie
natural bodybuilding you got to put on
the posing trunks the glutes come out
they have to be shredded and honest to
God it is so hard to explain how much
worse you feel going from like 98% done
with prep to 100% done like those last
couple pounds at the very edge or at the
very end of your prep that take you from
a classic physique level of conditioning
to a natural bodybuilding level it's
it's so hard to explain exactly how
terrible those last few pounds are so
for that reason number one is natural
bodybuilding which makes sense when you
think of all the money that gets dumped
into the sport usually where there's a
high level of competition difficulty
that's where the money goes so natural
bodybuilding the most talent the most
difficulty the highest stakes and the
number-one sport and in many ways
essentially the only sport ok question
for Greg from Ryan W and Ryan is a tall
person he is 6 foot 7 or approximately 2
meters for our friends that use the
metric system and Ryan's question is his
BMI has always put him on the high side
of overweight at 250 pounds and
basically the root of his question is is
the BMI scale built for normal height
people basically is his height biasing
his BMI and making it seem like he's
more overweight than then he should be
based on BMI yeah so probably something
you need to know about the BMI scale is
it was developed in the 1830s by Lambert
Adolph jacque's
quit let I hope I'm pronouncing that
right anyway Adolph wet lid that's how
we're going to say his name on this show
so anyway
his name's not that important the most
important thing is it was developed in
the 1830s and when he was you know
looking so it was developed based on
dissected corpses and based on the
dissected corpses that he
that and just kind of some knowledge of
how humans scale as they get bigger he
was like you know height or weight
certainly doesn't scale one-to-one with
height it seems to be somewhere between
second-order and third-order so you know
weights seems to scale with height
squared or height cubed realistically
probably somewhere in between if I had
to pick an ideal number it probably
scales with height raised to the 2-point
fifth power but it seems to be maybe a
little bit closer to two than three so
for BMI it's just going to be you know
body mass and kilograms divided by
height in meters squared but even when
it was developed he was like you know
two point five would probably be a
little better but like I said the
important thing it was developed in the
1830s not everyone had ti-89 graphing
calculators back then and certainly
didn't have a calculator on their phone
in their pocket at the time and so it
was really easy to raise stuff to the
second power really easy to raise stuff
to the third power a non-negligible
computational challenge to raise
something to the two and a half power
so BMI was developed as you know mass
divided by height to the second power
and that's what it is but even when it
was developed it was known it's probably
not perfect so the reason why this is
relevant is the the impact of scaling
height to the wrong like with the wrong
exponent isn't going to matter all that
much for people who are normal height
which is you know kind of for whom the
formula was developed but it's gonna
matter more and more for people who are
either way way considerably shorter than
average or way way considerably taller
than average so to use the example of
Ryan W who asked this question he's
approximately two meters tall and
approximately a hundred and fifteen
kilograms so if we plug that in
the current BMI formula 115 divided by 2
squared he comes out with a BMI of
almost twenty nine twenty eight point
seven five however if we use what was
you know at the time believed to be a
more appropriate exponent in which I
believe current like like ongoing
science has found is probably a better
exponent of two point five like height
raised to the power of two point five or
other than to his BMI thin would be
twenty point three which is normal and
so I think that they say twenty point
three yeah Wow yeah I mean for someone
two meters tall that makes it that's a
big difference so so yeah
and I mean if you've if you've ever seen
someone who's six foot seven or two
meters tall who weighs 250 pounds or
about 115 kilos like that to my eye is a
healthy weight on that frame so anyway
yeah so at six at six seven 250 you're
probably a perfectly healthy weight and
BMI is probably telling you you are
heftier than it likely should be telling
you based on the fact that BMI was
developed at a time when computational
power was severely limited so they just
developed a formula that worked well for
people who are around average height it
probably cuts the other way for people
who are considerably sure than average
so one one thing which I guess is
important is that like kind of normal
body height is able to skew high much
easier than it is able to skew short
unless someone has dwarfism of some of
some sort but you know kind of normal
height for people goes all the way down
to you know maybe five foot three for a
woman on the shorter side of things but
not an outlier by any by any stretch of
the imagination up to about six two ish
six three four men so you can skew
higher than that pretty
easily like there's a lot of people
without developmental conditions who are
six seven six eight six nine all the way
up to seven foot who don't maybe have
gigantism there aren't that many people
who are like four foot five without some
form of dwarfism so it's probably not as
extreme for really short people as it is
for really really tall people but it
probably does cut the other way as well
where there's you know some people who
are four foot eleven five feet tall that
BMI says are normal weight who are maybe
overweight
yeah so it's just purely purely a matter
of the the exponent not being perfect
for the BMI formula works reasonably
well for most people probably doesn't
work great for super jacked people
overall in general but in terms of even
general population works much more
poorly for people who are very very tall
and likely very very short as well I've
got a slightly related
I wouldn't say rant but I would say
tangent it is kind of wild when you
think of the number of things that we
still use and the reason we use them is
because of computational limitations
that no longer exist for sure but we
haven't updated it you know so like like
BMI we could do better but we don't why
does everybody use a p-value of 0.05
well because at a certain point they had
to print tables of either 0.0 0.0 1.0 5
or whatever you know that's why we had
specified cut-offs and then just say
we'll just report your p-value as a
continuous number well we can very
easily report exact p-values now
extremely easily but we still treat it
as a very very very rigid cutoff you
know there's one other I had in mind oh
yeah we talked about Bayesian statistics
a couple episodes ago got a lot of
surprisingly positive feedback on that I
think so I think people are trolling us
but you know like when you lay it out in
terms of the the general concept of what
each approach
doing Bayesian brings a lot to the table
mm-hmm but frequentist methods became
like the way to do it because the
computation was a lot more
straightforward before our computational
capacities caught up but still it's like
once something is ingrained based on
prior computational difficulties it's
very hard to get that inertia to budge
yeah I mean that as long as something
works well enough under most contexts
there's gonna be a lot of inertia so I
mean if if for some reason the human
population had another explosion in
height as the one that occurred during
the like early in middle part of the
20th century and you know the average
human height became six foot five
guarantee you we would get an update to
the BMI formula pretty quickly but for
the time being you know it doesn't work
great for a non-negligible amount of
people but it works you know pretty well
for ninety ninety-five percent of people
so there's just not that much energy
pushing for for it to change
similar with frequentist statistics like
they have issues but like they seem to
generally work well enough most of the
time for most applications so yeah
people just roll with them but yeah and
I mean of those examples dog like BMI is
way more egregious than frequentist
versus Bayesian statistics because you
know you still kind of need to
understand Bayesian statistics and like
there's it's not something that's like
super straightforward but like you know
literally the only difference between
the current BMI formula and what would
probably be a better BMI formula is like
when you type in divided by height
squared just add 0.5 to the end of it
and you know that that that's going to
take a quarter of a second on literally
every calculator in the world but yeah
people just don't do it do you think if
we start it over if we started fresh too
and said how are we gonna do this data
analysis thing do you still think we
would lean toward frequentist over
Bayesian if you ignored the the past
history of using it so much that's a
good question
I think we'd probably go Bayesian I
think we would too just because like a
Bayes factor is so much more explicitly
interpretable than a p-value as yeah I
think it would be just more like
inherently appealing and understandable
to people just learning about statistics
I agree
all right next question for Eric is from
Lee Tyler the question is is completely
issuing the debt the deadlift and all
deadlift variations acceptable from a
bodybuilding standpoint and if so if
that's the direction you lean can you
justify your answer so can you name a
couple of accomplished bodybuilders
who've reached their level without
incorporating deadlifts into their
training and then he finishes the
question to what extent can I make up
for deadlift gains with a bunch of other
exercises targeting the posterior chain
of four arms and upper traps so for
example good mornings leg curls lunges
shrugs and farmers walks yeah so this is
a good question I think a lot of people
have this question in mind especially
people who kind of dislike deadlift or
you know it just doesn't suit them well
you can absolutely ditch the deadlift as
a bodybuilder without question they held
my feet to the fire and asked for
specifics I think there are so many
bodybuilders that don't deadlift that
it's almost hard to find them like
there's not a lot of people who like
write tell-all articles of like I admit
it I'm a bodybuilder that doesn't
deadlift but like I mean I I grew up
watching the bodybuilding videos on you
know YouTube or the different like
muscle magazine websites I don't know if
I ever saw a deadlift in and one thing
I'll add here just because I could see
someone holding your feet to the fire
about this is they
specifically in the question can you
name a couple who have reached their
level without incorporating deadlifts
into their training so that could be
construed as you know well maybe they
did their dad maybe they did deadlifts
at some point and have now dropped them
but I think a fair response to that is
if they drop deadlifts and all of the
muscles deadlift trains they have since
been able to hypertrophy further then I
think one can logically infer that the
deadlift wasn't necessary to get to that
point yeah I mean if you can ditch it
and maintain the same level of success
or keep getting bigger or or build upon
that yeah and keep getting bigger then
it probably wasn't an absolutely
irreplaceable cornerstone of your
program now I love dead lifting and I
would say that the default approach
would be it it does have a very useful
place for many bodybuilders but but the
question is theoretically can you get by
without it and the answer to me is
unequivocally yes and I think there are
many many many high level bodybuilders
out there that do not regularly deadlift
or if they did deadlift during their
initial years of bodybuilding they have
since ditched it and are still doing
just fine without it
so definitely you can I mean I the
problem is I I follow Exercise Science
more than I follow bodybuilding so this
is like my big glaring weak spot for q
and A's is like to try to keep up with
who's doing what in the bodybuilding
world I have no idea
I read the research I train people I
train myself I don't really follow who's
doing what across the country but in any
case I mean like I said there's there's
just ample ample numbers of bodybuilders
out there that are not currently
deadlifting that are still doing just
fine now power lifting each deadlift
because you they're gonna make you do it
so what one way or another yeah they're
gonna make you do it unless you're a
bench specialist exactly at that point
are you really a power lifter oh wow
that's
those are shots to fire on another day
though yeah so but no but I mean because
it's lumped in with you know bench and
squat and everybody likes doing those I
think a lot of people assume like well
you have to do it if you're gonna
participate in any realm of strength or
physique sport but know you can get by
as a body builder without deadlifts just
fine the hamstring curl is a perfectly
suitable hamstring developer same as
like a glute ham raise hip thrusts are
fantastic for glute development you can
also get some glute development out of
your squats your lunges different back
extension variations step ups even the
glute kickback machine which honestly
people hate on it I don't know why I
think it's a pretty fine like if you're
if you're gonna use a machine for
isolation purposes not a bad machine at
all all sorts of stuff you can do to
help develop your lower back too many to
name if your lower back is resisting any
degree of loading you're doing
essentially what you were doing with the
deadlift I mean there's a million ways
to do that
rows and pull ups will give you plenty
of back thickness shrugs farmers walk
for traps most people really don't need
a lot of or most people don't really
need any direct forearm training
especially in bodybuilding I I would be
shocked if any body building judge is
factoring that in to their consideration
maybe if it's like the 99th criteria for
a tie breaker but yeah most bodybuilders
are not doing direct form work but there
are a lot of people who want to have big
forearms which is totally understandable
it's cool having big forums of course it
is so if you want big forearms but you
don't want a deadlift you can absolutely
do wrist curls they'll get you there you
know so so yeah absolutely the general
premise is you can do all sorts of
different variations to individually
make up for what you've lost by ditching
the deadlift
now I will say deadlifts are awesome and
unless we cannot use deadlifts I've got
all my clients doing some some form of a
deadlift whether it's an RDL or a single
leg rtl with like a dumbbell or
kettlebell or you know sumo conventional
deadlift I'm hitting all sorts of
deadlift variations
me and my clients but every now and then
you're gonna get a client who we
shouldn't be deadlifting because they've
got an injury history or something like
that or they just hate it and they say
Eric please don't make me deadlift in
that case we just don't we do all sorts
of other stuff we still get great
development all the way down the
posterior chain and we're just fine but
but the main benefit with a deadlift the
reason I do my default stance is to keep
it in if we can is because it is
efficient as hell rather than doing all
these 9 different accessory exercises to
hit this group in that group and the
other that's the beauty of the compound
lifts if we can just load up a
technically sound heavy deadlift we're
going to be training everything on the
backside of the body between their ears
and their heels and that's a pretty cool
thing ok question for Gregg this
question concerns getting more sleep on
average it's easy for me to get 7 to 8
hours of sleep per night recently my
training demands have increased
dramatically I've been trying to get
more sleep per night 8 to 9 hours or
more but I frequently run into an issue
my sleep quality seems to go down and I
end up either waking up earlier or
waking up more during the night
resulting in poor sleep I'm employ every
protocol that I can think of in terms of
just general sleep hygiene stuff but I
can't manage to sleep more is this
indicative that I shouldn't be trying to
force more sleep and should just return
to my normal sleep habits yes so this is
a good question and I think that I think
in the past I may have just given the
blanket recommendation of trying to get
more sleep maybe without providing
enough nuance but anyway yeah there
there is kind of more going on here
so first things first the reason that
Bruce the the asker here might be
wanting to get more sleep is that to
this point it seems like sleep extension
is probably one of the best things
people can do to support heart training
and get more out of their training make
more progress should be noted this
hasn't been tested in the context
of like strength sports or assistance
training yet but the research that is
out there that looks at a variety of
different sports from tennis to
basketball to swimming - I think there
was even a recent study on like middle
distance runners all finds that taking
pretty high level athletes so most of
these studies use like a d1 collegiate
athlete so people who are quite good
athletes having them go from there like
habitual six to eight hours of sleep per
night to 9 plus or even 10 plus hours
per night seems to result in pretty
notable improvements in performance
within reasonably short periods of time
so just like a couple weeks and so if
you're having issues recovering from
training and you can sleep more that's
that's one of the first things I'd
recommend you know making sure you're
eating enough total calories and protein
and making sure you're sleeping enough
however there are a few things to note
about that so as I mentioned the vast
majority of those studies are I think
maybe all of those studies have used
collegiate athletes I think the the
recent one on runners may not have but
regardless like most of those studies
use high-level collegiate athletes one
important thing to note about sleep is
as the pineal gland ages you release
less melatonin through the night and
sleep duration just naturally trends
down so children can very comfortably
sleep 9 to 10 hours per night by the
time someone's in their 70s or 80s I
don't have the exact numbers in front of
me but I know that like typical sleep
durations drop off quite a bit just
because they don't have as much
melatonin to keep them asleep and
sedated anymore so you know sleep
durations could drop from you know seven
to eight hours a night for a typical
adult down to you know five six seven
hours a night for like acceptance for
example so in
that could be relevant for you know
looking at research on college athletes
versus say a middle-aged person who
listens to this podcast very well could
be possible for you know 21 year old
college athlete who feels decent
sleeping 8 hours per day to start
getting 10 plus hours of sleep per night
but that very well may just not be
possible even if you're not old like
even if you're 35 40 45 years old at
that point your ability to rip off 10
hours of sleep in a clip may just not be
there anymore because you probably do
have some aging of your pineal gland so
the exact amount of time is you know I
think important here if like so like I
said 10 plus hours is used in some of
the research maybe 8 to 9 hours
is sleep extension for a middle-aged
person we don't really have that
research yet because again we don't have
that many studies and most of them use
pretty young athletes next thing I would
say is that it can absolutely do more
harm than good to just try to force
yourself to get more sleep than you
actually need just kind of on a
practical level that can stress you out
sleep is supposed to be relaxing if you
think like oh I need to get this sleep
and I can't get it suddenly like you're
kind of tired but you're still in bed
can't fall asleep like that that happens
to me all the time so I wouldn't
necessarily try to force getting more
sleep and saying like I have to sleep
this period of time and if I don't it's
bad what I think I would generally
recommend if you want to try a sleep
extension strategy is trying to go to
bed maybe like an hour earlier than you
typically do and to the best of your
ability just try to wake up without an
alarm and so like you know let's say you
have to wake up at 7 every day to get to
work by 8:00 8:30 whatever it is you
know if you're getting eight hours per
night maybe you're typically going to
bed at 11 p.m. if you move your bedtime
forward to 10 p.m.
and you're still waking up to that alarm
at 7:00 like if that's still you know
seemingly not as much sleep as your body
wants you know maybe try moving your bed
time forward another 30 minutes or so
but but you know I think that a good
general rule of thumb is if you're able
to wake up without an alarm you're
probably getting as much sleep as your
body wants and needs and I would I think
practically just you know try to get
that from moving your bed time forward
slightly rather than saying like here's
a fixed amount of sleep I have to get
every night and if I don't it's bad if
you you know if you naturally wake up
and you don't have to use an alarm after
eight hours of sleep I think that's
probably a good general indication that
that's as much sleep as your body means
that's as much as it's craving and I
don't think you know stubbornly laying
there for an hour and trying to force
yourself to get another hour of sleep is
really going to accomplish that much for
you
another thing that I'll note about the
research as well is in addition to them
being young athletes they were also I
mean d1 athletes are very very serious
athletes so you know you say that your
training demands have increased
dramatically that very well may be the
case but it also very well may be the
case that you're still not you know
putting in as much training and as hard
of training as a d1 athlete would be so
you know whereas they may really benefit
from getting an extra two hours of sleep
per night because they are just training
so hard for you you know if you were
training kind of comfortably before and
now training demands have gone up quite
a bit maybe what would be like the
optimal amount of sleep extension for
you is 30 minutes or an hour not a
dramatic amount so anyway I feel like
that was a little bit rambley but just
kind of to bring it all home the total
amount you're going to be able to sleep
does vary person to person but as is
pretty strongly dependent on age if
you're you know I would say probably
more than thirty thirty-five years old
you're just
find it really hard to sleep 9 or more
hours per night in general the
difficulty of your training probably
matters pretty substantially here as
well in all likelihood you may be
training hard by your standards but
probably aren't training that hard by d1
athlete standards so you may just simply
not need the same degree of sleep
extension they do and just as a general
rule of thumb if you find yourself being
able to wake up naturally without
needing and alarm to wake you up I think
in general assuming you don't have some
sort of like sleep
condition you are probably getting about
as much sleep as your body wants and
needs so that's that's how I would
answer that question do you have
anything to add Rex no I mean I think
we've all been there in those situations
where you know that it would benefit you
to be sleeping but you're unable to
sleep and then you like stretch yourself
out and then you can't sleep because
you're stressed because you wish you
were sleeping that's not a state that
you want to put yourself into frequently
so if you're trying to force from if
you're trying to force yourself to go
from a normal amount of sleep to a
higher than normal amount of sleep and
it's not working I really want to spend
a whole lot of time trying to force it
which is completely in line with what
you said all right then so moving on to
the next question for Eric from Josh VL
are you ever concerned about a client
having high creatine levels my doctor
mentioned that I should stop taking
creatine because my levels were above
the recommended levels i disregarded the
advice but was curious on your take okay
so I'm assuming you say high creatine
levels you mean high creatinine levels
so creatinine is a breakdown product of
creatine and under normal circumstances
that if your creatinine levels are
higher than normal that would be
indicative of impaired kidney function
and under normal circumstances that
would certainly be a problematic thing
and you would want to figure out the
root cause of why your kidney function
seems to be impaired now if you're
consuming an abnormal amount of creatine
which you know
if you take a creatine supplement you
are I think normal like typical dietary
creatine intake in an omnivorous diet is
probably like a gram or two a day at
most
unless you're seeking out additional
sources and really hitting it hard
unless you're one of the people who's
super hardcore and you're on the wrong
car navour diet right yes in if that's
the case you can actually consume quite
a bit of creatine okay but for most
typical diets a gram maybe two a day so
if you're taking a 5 gram scoop or you
know loading creatine yeah your
creatinine is going to go up and that's
not necessarily indicative of anything
to do with your kidney it just means you
put in a lot of the precursor it got
broken down and now you're eliminating
the breakdown product so what happens is
your doctor probably I'm going to make a
list of assumptions here that may or may
not be true probably not from a lifting
background or a sports medicine
background where they took a keen
interest in creatine probably learned
during med school rightfully so that
under normal circumstances a high
creatinine value is a bad thing and so
when they see it they probably say hey
this is abnormal stop doing things that
make it abnormal but realistically if
you're taking creatine it essentially
makes the the plasma creatinine test an
invalid test you you have skewed the
results of that test and the outcome
there is no longer it no longer means
what it used to because you've skewed it
now you know and if you look at the
different creatine studies over the
years they see high elevated creatinine
levels all the time and it's never
resulted in anything catastrophic in
those studies and one thing just to note
as well is if you hear the same thing
about alt and ast results which are
generally indicative of liver function
they're also they also tend to just be
naturally elevated if you're doing
strenuous resistance training as well
yeah I had a friend who sent me their
their blood test results their doctor
was freaked out because their creatine
kinase was abnormal their creatinine was
abnormal and both of those liver enzymes
were
normal and the doctors like the dude
you're essentially dying there's
something you you have you have major
multiple organ failure going on right
now and I was like no it looks like you
just take creatine and you lift probably
more than you should you know he even he
was he had some serious weight room
ambition and was just he was training
hard but but it was still just normal
responses to very heavy training and
creatine intake but now that that takes
me to the actionable part of this let's
say you're on creatine you go to the
doctor and the creatinine values high
the appropriate way to handle that in my
opinion and this is not medical advice
but if it were me I would say well
doctor I am on creatine and I understand
that should elevate my creatinine levels
beyond the normal range however it would
make sense to follow up and do
additional testing to make sure that I
don't have impaired kidney function or
or let's use some other information that
might tell us whether or not there could
be an underlying kidney problem so that
that's the thing is you don't want to
assume always like well no surely there
could never possibly be anything wrong
but you would want to be very
transparent with your doctor and say
this particular test is skewed by my
dietary practices are there other ways
we can maybe just do a follow-up to make
sure everything's okay
in terms of my kidney function they it
should be pretty straightforward pretty
easy to do but yeah so a lot of times
you'll see people who you know their
creatine kinase is high which is due to
muscle damage from training their little
liver enzymes are high their their
creatinine is high and their doctors
freaked out and most the time it's
completely benign okay Greg question for
you okay so yeah a question for Greg
from trend baloney
I heard Greg once say that one reason
he's never taken anabolic steroids is
their potential impact on cognition but
I've never seen anyone else referenced
that as a side effect could Greg
elaborate I certainly can so yeah one
thing that I should throw out there just
to start is most of the research
actually on living humans and not cell
culture and and buy most of it I think I
mean all of it is just cross-sectional
research if you if you're a researcher
and you think that you can give someone
a chemical that's not going to treat
some sort of disease but it has the
potential to you know kill brain cells
and decrease cognitive function the IRB
is gonna say yeah thanks but no thanks
we're not gonna sign off on that so it's
a it's not something you can necessarily
do our CTS on and so the best we have in
humans is is cross-sectional research
which you know standard caveat supply
can't necessarily infer causation but
what is out there
and the thing that put this on mate on
my radar is a study by Borna Beck I hope
I'm saying that right title it for
anyone who wants to Google this is
structural brain imaging of long term
anabolic androgenic steroid users and
non-users this was published back in
2017 and essentially what they did in
the study is they found a group of
steroid users and non-users who were
quite similar on like the vast majority
of relevant like health behaviors and
socio demographic factors that could
impact you know brain health or
cognitive function to you know try to to
the greatest degree possible isolate
just the effect of anabolic steroids and
so what they found in this study is that
the so they looked at it they did brain
scans to look at various brain
structures and some of the brain
structures were smaller in the anabolic
steroid users
one might want to assume that that means
that those brain regions had atrophied
we can't necessarily assume that they
had atrophied because again it wasn't a
longitudinal study but that is kind of
the implication there including so some
of the the brain regions that were
smaller included just total brain gray
matter which is ingrate and the cerebral
cortex which also isn't great that's
where most of your conscious thought
goes on and then they also found in in
the steroid user groups their measures
of verbal IQ were lower as well and that
particularly scares me because you know
most of my 9 to 5 is I'm a writer
you know I interpret science I coach
people but ultimately how I make most of
my money is is writing about this stuff
so if if again if these were
longitudinal changes and not just you
know some other factor explaining it if
my verbal IQ went down that would be
very bad for me both personally and
professionally
and so like again as I've said for like
the eighth time now cross-sectional
study all standard caveat supply but it
should also be noted that in terms of
like cell culture and like mechanistic
work we know that for example the the
person asking this their their name
trend baloney is a little ironic here
because trend has been found to be
directly neurotoxic and just like
androgens in general above a certain
threshold also exhibit neurotoxicity so
there is a mechanism by which we we
could assume that taking steroids does
call some of those negative changes in
the brain longitudinally like I said
since it is cross-sectional research
another completely valid option here is
that maybe just people at baseline with
some of those differences in in like
brain structure may have just naturally
been more drawn to using steroids so you
know maybe it's that people with on
average less brain gray matter and
smaller cerebral Court use cerebral
cortexes are going to be more drawn to
use steroids than people who don't
that's also and I don't I don't intend
that as a burn by the way but that is
something that is entirely possible as
well and given the fact that this is
cross-sectional research we can't rule
it out
so anyway the the link between steroids
and potential brain issues and cognitive
issues is not as strong as safe a link
between steroids and balding or steroids
and cratering HDL levels like those are
things that we actually have
longitudinal human evidence to support
so it's not something that's like as as
firmly established as those things but
there's enough going on here both in
terms of cross-sectional research and
mechanistic research that it it concerns
me enough to kind of scare me away from
it
now like I said so so Tran itself seems
to be directly neurotoxic even at
relatively small concentrations I
wouldn't be shocked if like kind of the
idea of like u-tube natty doses weren't
necessarily all that bad so you know
maybe if you go on like slightly super
physiological doses of Justice dosterone
but nothing crazy and not throwing in a
bunch of accessories I could very well
it would not be difficult to convince me
that that's not going to have much of a
negative effect on cognition or brain
function or anything whatsoever like I I
would strongly assume that if this is
like a causative thing there is probably
some sort of dose response relationship
here with you know higher doses being
more deleterious but I also know that
I'm the person that
if I do something I don't do
half-measures I kind of feel like if I
ever went on gear it would be like ah
let's try a little bit let's get some
more gains let's see how this goes and
in like 18 months I just be on
everything in the kitchens everything in
the kitchen sink and like just become a
meme on the steroids subreddit where
it's just like holy [ __ ] how's this guy
taking so much like like I know myself
well enough to know that if I stick my
toes in those waters that is what I
would do and so anyway those are my
general thoughts in terms of why it's
not as well known I think it's not as
well known because the research that's
out is like pretty recent so I think
most of these things were found in the
last five years or so whereas the impact
on like cardiovascular health or like
hair and stuff like that most of that
was established 20-30 years ago so it's
had longer to disseminate and also like
I said I'm not making any claims that we
know for sure that these are
longitudinal changes that happen the the
evidence is admittedly much more murky
than it is for some of the other more
well-known side effects of steroids so I
think that's one of the reasons you're
probably the biggest reason you haven't
seen many other people talking about it
it's less well supported it's less well
known yeah those are I would say my
general thoughts on the on the topic so
I share that same character trait where
like if I'm gonna do something I'm gonna
like go as far as I possibly can with it
dude here's what's gonna happen
listeners you need to stay tuned to the
stronger by science media empire for the
next like 20 years because one of these
days me and treks are gonna get old
we're gonna go on HRT oh yeah and then
two years after that we're gonna be the
biggest [ __ ] 65 year old mass
monsters you've ever seen
yeah I mean so with natural bodybuilding
I've had periods of time where my tea is
low like out of the normal reference
range it's horrible I pretty much
decided immediately when I had my first
droppin test I was like oh dude when I
hit that in I'm going on HRT
that's not a medical recommendation but
that's how I'm gonna choose to live my
life but I really do believe that I'll
probably like hang up my competition
trunks I'll be old I'll go on HRT and
then I'll probably after my competitive
career achieve my peak physique at the
age of like six and three hey have you
seen have you seen those commercials for
I think it's just like an anti-aging
clinic where it's basically just you
know if you're old enough we're gonna
give you all of the tests and growth
hormone you could ever want
and kind of the frontman for it is this
doctor who's like 70 plus years old and
looks like an incredibly jacked mister
magoo never never seen it it's it's
something worth googling anyway I could
definitely see myself going that route
as well oh yeah all right so next
question for Eric is from Wilma Larsen
so Wilma says or asks more and more
studies show that a plant-based diet is
healthier than one that includes meat
and other animal products how does this
relate to gains and weight loss so this
is a topic that's been in the news
lately obviously last episode we talked
a little bit about a documentary called
the game changers that talked about
switching to plant-based diets it talked
about different health and performance
related outcomes and how they relate to
either plant-based diets or omnivorous
diets so first I want to push back a
little bit about the the premise of the
question so it kind of says you know
more and more studies show that a
plant-based diet is healthier than one
that includes meat I'm not ready to get
on board with that premise yet I think
you could definitely say that there are
many observational studies showing that
people who tend to choose plant-based
diets have better long-term health
outcomes than people who don't but
there's a very very big confounding
influence there of the fact that a lot
of people who adopt plant-based diets
tend to be pretty health conscious
individuals who have made a pretty
serious commitment to make
health related sacrifices so can I just
ask a question real quick just about
definitions yeah
so it seems like both this question and
your answer so far is assuming that
plant-based diets is synonymous with a
vegetarian and vegan diets mm-hmm my
understanding was that you could very
much have an omnivorous plan based diet
where it's essentially you know you eat
some meat eat a bunch of plants you just
cut out a lot of processed junk like
like almost like a paleo diet where you
just eat a ton of fruits and veggies I
wouldn't see a problem with
operationalizing it that way cuz I'm not
sure if there is a true singular
definition of plant-based diet but in
this question if it can creates a
dichotomy of plant-based diet versus one
that includes meat or other animal
products no I got you I I was genuinely
curious cuz I am NOT a participant in
that discussion at all but I know I've
seen plant-based diet as a term used to
also describe like generally healthy
omnivorous diets yeah so I don't know if
that was like a generally incorrect
usage of that term or if this question
was using it incorrectly like I'm I'm
just curious about what the kind of
common definition is the way I've seen
it used lately in conversation and I'm
not tapped into the vegan vegetarian
world either so I don't know if there
are competing definitions going around
but the interpretation I've seen most
commonly recently is that a plant-based
diet is vegetarian if not vegan or no
but I could see you saying well that's
that's not necessarily what it should
mean but but what based on the way the
question is phrased we'll just
operationalize it that way going you
know and move forward from there that
works so yeah but like I said a lot of
times what those studies are
accidentally or unintentionally doing is
comparing what are the outcomes of very
health focused individuals compared to
people who aren't particularly health
focused and obviously that's going
have big implications for their exercise
habits whether or not they smoke how
often and how much they drink alcohol a
whole host of health-related behaviors
so I I'm not ready to say that
unequivocally a diet that excludes
animal products is more healthy than a
diet that includes some animal products
now if you gravitate toward a
plant-based diet or a vegan diet we'll
say just to be more specific there are
many many justifiable reasons to do that
so I you know I definitely don't want
people to think I'm anti vegan diets
there are very defensible ethical
reasons to do it whether they pertain to
the welfare of animals or different
environmental reasons I'm an expert in
neither of those areas so not I'm not
going to further that conversation in
any way but it's it's very defensible
and understandable some people also find
that when they gravitate toward a vegan
diet like I said once they buy in to
making more health-related sacrifices or
decisions it has an effect on other
health-related decisions they make so
when they stick to their vegan diet they
eat more vegetables more fiber they eat
less you know objectively crappy foods
you know they eat less foods that cause
them to overeat or increase their
likelihood of overeating that are hyper
palatable foods that have extremely high
energy density so some people it makes
sense because they adopt the vegan diet
and they adopt a whole like category of
positive health-related behaviors and
that's totally fine and you can make a
vegan diet work extremely well you can
be a fantastic athlete on a vegan diet
but I push back against against the idea
that there is it an unequivocal
categorical nutritional advantage to a
vegan diet compared to an omnivorous
diet so directly to the question it
should have no bearing on weight gain or
weight loss really what we're looking at
there is making sure your total energy
intake is appropriate for your weight
gain or your weight loss goal and making
sure that your macron
treant proportions are suitable as well
now if the macro nutrient intakes are
matched between a vegan diet and an
omnivorous diet you should expect that
the results in terms of performance and
body composition would be either neutral
you know no benefit either way or they
might slightly favored the omnivorous
diet due to issues related to protein
quality however if you just made small
adjustments to account for that
difference in protein quality and you
made sure that within your vegan diet
you were getting adequate intake of all
the key essential amino acids that you
need then any small benefit to the
omnivorous diet would probably disappear
so you can set up two equally awesome
diets whether they're vegan or
omnivorous whether your goal is to gain
muscle or to lose fat and then of course
if it's vegetarian and not vegan at that
point becomes super easy oh yes you have
plenty of high quality protein sources
at your disposal absolutely anything
egg-based anything dairy based you've
got also all sorts of options there so
that's why I use vegan as the extreme
example that's the one that you have to
actually get a little bit more creative
but do it for a while i honest to god I
probably spent about two in probably two
years or so essentially as a novo
lacto-vegetarian which basically means
I'll eat egg products eat dairy products
but no meat or fish the only reason was
cuz I was too lazy to cook meat and fish
honestly no I mean I've been there as
well
like I look I like eggs in the morning
and then if I'm super busy and don't
feel like cooking anything or just like
straight up dog I eat a lot of meat and
sometimes I just get tired of it and
just don't want to eat meat for like a
week yeah and I used to eat a lot of
cottage cheese and yogurt and recently
I've really been into skier and like
I'll just be quarts of skier a day and
I'm perfectly happy with that oh yeah
yeah I mean for a while there it was
whey protein Greek yogurt and eggs and I
was totally content yes just because I
was lazy and when you're like a college
student and you share a kitchen with six
19 year old guy
essentially every time you cook you're
risking your life there are all sorts of
bacteria in that kitchen some of which
probably haven't been identified by
modern science so yeah I just didn't
cook much okay so just to so I think
I've answered the question itself pretty
directly I'd like to use an example here
to clarify my views on plant-based
versus omnivorous diet so it is a
hundred percent possible to have an
omnivorous diet that is totally full of
nutrient-dense plants and phytochemicals
you have some animal products in there
but you know the bait the bulk of your
diet you've got all sorts of vegetables
and fruits a variety of intakes that is
an excellent high quality diet it's
totally possible to have an insanely
terrible plant-based diet that has no
animal products it's not that hard just
to think of any shitty junk food that
doesn't have animal products in it eat
all of that congratulations you're the
least healthy vegan on the planet I mean
so I know I know several vegan power
lifters and a couple of them do have
really good high-quality diets but kind
of the running joke among the rest of
them is just like a vegan powerlifting
diet is tofu vegenaise and Oreos like
that is a ball disgusting the second of
all not an ideal diet to facilitate your
performance and body comp but so this
idea of treating them is categorical and
one is better than the other it doesn't
make a lot of sense a diet has a lot of
components that are that are all
important and you got to make sure
whether it's vegan or omnivorous you've
got all your bases covered so if you
told me if you know what I'm gonna do is
reduce my intake of processed meats
lower my animal fat intake and I'm gonna
replace some of those choices with
fibrous vegetables because currently I
don't eat any of them you've made good
substitutions these are objectively good
substitutions to make assuming all other
things are equal if you're going from a
diet that's super high in processed
fatty animal prod
and you had no vegetables previously and
you're making that type of swap of
course that's a step up you're doing a
good thing based on everything we know
about nutrition if you were on a good
like well-put-together Mediterranean
type diet and you told me that you're
gonna swap out your fish or your poultry
and put in tofu instead I don't see that
as a particularly beneficial swap so
there there are times where people adopt
these types of like oh I'm gonna do this
like more plant-based switch sometimes
it is an objective improvement in the
diet sometimes it's totally negligible
so with this and last week talking about
that documentary I think I've said
everything I ever hope to say about
vegan and vegetarian diets ok so last
question for Gregg this one is from Jack
Quint I was wondering if you guys could
provide any advice for students that are
looking to improve their writing skills
for science-based fitness articles
related to that what would be a useful
approach for getting published on
well-known websites and I just want to
mention that's a really well-written
question is I very boldly was like I'm
gonna read this one verbatim usually we
can't so you you Jack you're already a
very good question writer
congratulations on that
that is true so I'll give you some
advice here and this is advice coming
from me and kind of the route that I
took I will say that it's it's probably
different depending on what background
you're coming from so for example I know
quite a few people who do have an
academic background they were used to
writing a lot for journal publications
and then they tried to get into writing
fitness articles for a lay audience and
you know their struggles with trying to
develop more of like a lay press
friendly voice we're very different from
mine just trying to figure out how to
write period because I got into this
before I had really any meaningful
writing skills but anyway so some of
some of the things that helped me out
quite a bit were one just just
practicing I don't really do this
anymore
but when I was first you know kind of
like I'm putting my thoughts out there
in the world people seem to kind of
enjoy my writing I want more people to
read it and so I want to get better at
this one of the things I did for a long
time is I just had a rule where I wrote
a thousand words a day didn't matter if
they were good words didn't matter if
they were bad words most of them never
saw the light of day but just simply
putting pen to paper and trying to write
something that is at least decent it's
the same way you would go about
practicing a sport same way to go you'd
go about practicing technique for the
big three in the gym you want to get
better at something practice helps quite
a bit so then moving beyond just pure
practice and just putting words on a
page is you want to try to make that
practice purposeful and worthwhile and
so one of the things that helps
tremendously with that is to get an
editor you so I was pretty fortunate in
here
my wife she worked professionally as a
copy editor her background is in
journalism when I needed someone to tell
me all of the ways in which I sucked
tremendously as a writer she was there
for that do you think people should hire
an editor just marry one ideally marry
one but hire one if you must yeah so one
of the things I was gonna say is like if
you're just trying to get started as a
writer and you're not currently making
money at it it may be kind of hard to
justify hiring an editor and I totally
get that but you know you may be able to
do like a quid pro quo of sorts with a
buddy of yours who is proficient writer
or editor of some sort you know maybe
you know you do programming for them and
they do and they like edit your writing
for you and give you pointers
whatever but just trying to develop a
relationship with an editor in some way
shape or form I think will help a lot
because I think all of us I think all of
us kind of know good writing when we see
it and we know really bad writing when
we see it but unless you're unless
you're someone who has like a writing
background or like a English grammar
background and assuming you're trying to
write in English it's hard to it's hard
to really distinguish the two it's kind
of like you know it's kind of like
watching a film like you get out of a
movie and you're like oh I liked that
movie or I didn't like that movie and
maybe you can pick up on some stuff like
Oh some of those acting performances
were really bad or like oh some of those
explosions looked really fake or
whatever but you're probably not going
to be able to pick up on the subtleties
of it that like a professional film
critic might be able to I think writing
is very similar there are people who you
know critically appraise writing
professionally and they're going to be
better at that than you are and they're
simply just going to understand the way
the language works better than you do so
an editor will help you just both get
better at the mechanics of writing so
you know word choice punctuation
sentence structure how your paragraphs
flow together and then also kind of the
more like artistic and stylistic aspects
of writing so like you know how is your
stuff structured are you developing
arguments well etc you know you can you
can certainly figure all of that stuff
out on your own but if you know someone
who does that professionally and has a
better grasp on it than you do that'll
help a lot and also you're just getting
another set of eyes on it and another
set of critical eyes it's it's hard to
objectively evaluate really just your
own work period but especially your own
writing or at least I found so you know
once you've practiced once you've got an
editor to help you out with some stuff
another thing that's very useful is just
to run articles by your friends who are
in your target demographic just to make
sure that a they make sense and be they
resonate so an article could be
well-written technically but maybe just
completely go over the heads of the
people you want to read it and enjoy it
or it may be way too basic and they're
like oh this seems to be well-written
but I know all of this [ __ ] already why
are you wasting my time so there's kind
of like there's a process of triggering
out like a level to pitch your articles
at that it's going to be useful and
relevant for the people you want it to
be useful and relevant for but it's not
going to go over too many heads and just
making sure you put that in the hands of
the people who you want to read and like
it to see if they actually enjoy reading
it and getting something and get
something out of it I think is is a
pretty big step as well then like at any
given point in this process another
thing I'd recommend is just putting your
work out there in the world so you're
getting targeted feedback from an editor
you're getting targeted feedback from
friends and your target demographic and
then something that helps and will also
help tear your ego down a little bit is
just putting your work out into the
world publishing it on a blog and
getting feedback and criticism from the
masses some of its going to be useful
some of its not going to be useful but I
find or at least I found for myself that
when I win from knowing that whatever I
can just put this out on the web and no
one will see it - oh [ __ ] people are
gonna see this and if it [ __ ] sucks
I'm gonna hear about it just that kind
of added level of accountability helped
to make me a much better writer because
I knew that
you know initially the stakes were very
low but there were at least stakes so I
think that that's an important aspect as
well and then I would say once you kind
of get a handle on the writing process
you kind of get a handle on your writing
voice I would say another thing that
helps a
is like just not publishing stuff just
to publish stuff one of the things
you'll notice if you go back through the
stronger by science archives is as time
has gone on we've published stuff less
and less frequently part of that is just
because like I've had less and less to
say I'm not the type of person who wants
to write the same article half a dozen
times just so I have a fresh version on
of it on the site to drive clicks like
when I've said what I want to say I'd
much rather just kind of go back and
edit an old article instead of write a
completely new one on literally the
exact same topic so that so that's part
of it but then also like I only publish
something when I feel like I have
something that's worthwhile to say and
add to the conversation and also
something that is my best work or at
least quite good work and so like I
think one trap that a lot of people fall
in that kind of stymies their
development as a writer is like they are
writing a lot and they are putting reps
in but they're not purposefully trying
to make those reps better so like to
this day I still write way more than I
publish like I would say maybe one out
of every six words that I write actually
gets put on the website in some way
shape or form so you know just generally
taking pride in your work and trying to
make your next article better than your
last one like I would say as a general
rule of thumb if you look back on stuff
you wrote two years ago two years ago
and don't just hate it you're you're
probably not doing it right and I mean
if you've been writing for ten years and
it's like oh I'm twelve years into the
process now and the stuff I wrote ten
years into the process is still pretty
good then that's fine
but if you're just starting out the
stuff you wrote when you'd been writing
for a year if you don't hate that at the
point when you've been writing for three
years you probably that probably doesn't
mean the stuff you wrote when you were a
year in was great it probably means you
haven't improved that much in the
intervening two years so just as kind of
a check if you look back on old stuff
and you're not kind of like oh this kind
of sucks compared to my current stuff I
think that's generally bad
sign okay so then the second part of
that question is how to go about getting
published on well-known websites and
first piece of advice which apparently
doesn't occur to a lot of people is like
ask I think a lot of people are hoping
that you know they put stuff on a blog
and an editor of a big website is just
going to peruse their blog one day and
say oh this person is good
I should email them and get them to
write for my big website and like that
can happen but that's incredibly rare
most of the writing gigs I've gotten is
just like you know I'd read a website I
like a website I'm like I wish my work
was on this website and I pitched
something like you have to take
initiative if you're going to to get on
a lot of big websites so in terms of how
to make that go as smoothly as possible
is one check out their style guidelines
most big websites have style guidelines
and if you don't see it on the website
and you can't find it via Google één
email the editor or like whoever you
would be pitching articles to and say
hey do you have style guidelines I could
take a peek at like I can almost
guarantee you if like we have style
guidelines
I don't think literally anyone ever
looks at them but if if someone wanted
to submit a guest article and they
emailed me first and said hey could you
send me your style guidelines I promise
you that person would have a much larger
chance of me eventually accepting the
article because what you want to do is
you want to make the editors life as
easy as possible
they're probably reviewing a lot of
guest article submissions they they're
probably a busy person you want to make
their life as easy as possible so one if
they have style guidelines whatever
drafts you submit submit them already
like tailored to style guidelines then
in the initial interaction if you assume
mean you could already find the style
guidelines what you want to do is you
want to
hich article ideas to the site you want
to ask for make sure that those article
ideas make sense for the site so like
for example if you wanted to write for
tea nation and you have a draft ready
about bodybuilding and you have a draft
ready about yoga you probably don't want
to pitch the yoga idea to tea nation
like you'd probably want to pitch the
bodybuilding an idea so you know pitch
things that you already have drafts
ready for and based on what you pitch
demonstrate that you understand what the
website is what type of articles they
publish and who their audience is you
don't have to just like write out oh
here's what you're about here's what
your audience is but like it should be
pretty clear from the pitch that you
understand what that site is and what
it's about and then you know like I said
make sure you have a draft ready make
sure that that draft is already within
the style guidelines so if someone says
like hey I have an idea for an article
would you be interested in seeing a
draft I'm like oh yeah sure that sounds
cool and then I don't hear back from the
person for like a month and they say oh
here's the draft then I'm already kind
of peeved because like one that tells me
that that wasn't a high priority for
them which I don't know if I'm justified
in being peeved because you know they
probably do have more important things
going on but as an editor you want to
feel like your site is important to the
people writing for it so ya have a draft
ready to go if they say I'd like to see
a draft have a draft that you can go
ahead and shoot over like I said make
sure it's in the site style guidelines
already and just ultimately at every
step in the process just ask yourself am
I making the editor's life easier or
harder and if the answer is harder don't
[ __ ] do it because ultimately whether
or not you get to write further for the
site depends on whether the editor likes
you and your content if they don't like
you they're probably not gonna like your
content so just make the editors life
easy yeah the thing I would add because
all that stuff's good the thing I would
add is for a lot of people there's a lot
of people are a little bit nervous about
putting their stuff out for the first
time on a
relatively big platform because most
people don't like to have their work
criticized some people are more
sensitive to it than others but nobody
likes it but the thing I always remind
myself if I ever get that feeling of
like what if people hate it that's just
part of the game like my whole thing is
if you don't want your work or your
words to be criticized keep them to
yourself but then once you put something
out there you have to accept that some
people are gonna maybe dislike it maybe
hate it and that's just part of the cost
of admission when you get into the game
of publishing anything and so that's the
way it goes you put your information out
there whether it's written or audio or
whatever the case may be some people are
gonna think you're an idiot and nowadays
they'll just tell you like the Internet
it's good for that that's fine it's the
important thing is try to learn from it
being able to take feedback objectively
and say like wow three people told me
this thing maybe there's something to it
and actually implement that implementing
feedback without getting defensive
without getting upset that that's really
a huge key like you talked about growing
as a writer and definitely I look back
at things I wrote a long time ago and
they suck and I hate them but the only
way you get there is if along the way
you solicit feedback but more
importantly you accept it you implement
it thoughtfully and you continue to work
on those skills I agree so one thing I
would like to add in closing is you have
made it to the end of yet another Q&A
episode of the stronger by science
podcast if you enjoy the Q&A episodes or
if you haven't listened through all of
them yet or if you just want to go back
and listen to the greatest hits and get
our hot takes about certain subjects we
now have pages on the website which are
an archive of our Q&A s and the topics
we've covered on the podcast where you
can you know just ctrl F in the page
search for certain topic certain
questions we have them categorized as
well and you can and it will take you to
a page where it takes
to the timestamp where we addressed that
question or topic on the podcast so it
just makes you know kind of navigating
our library a lot easier than if you
know you know we've discussed something
before you want to listen back on it or
you're trying to make your way through
the archives and you know you don't
necessarily want to listen to every
single second of the podcast up to this
point to get caught up and you just are
more interested in certain topics than
others like whatever the whatever the
issue may be you can go to stronger by
science comm /q a and it's gonna pull up
a page called Q&A database and from
there you can you know find all of the
questions we filled it in all of the
topics we have discussed on the podcast
just to work your way through our
archives more efficiently or to as it
were relive the hits so again that is
stronger by science comm /qa awesome now
there is one final question this week
Gil 6:20 asks when will Greg become a
permanent accepted host of your show
permanent is a long time so we're not
ready to go quite there but I am happy
to announce that I have extended an
offer to bring Greg as a special guest
co-host for episode number 26 of the
podcast
that'll be airing one week two from
today as you guys know episodes go up
every single Thursday thanks again as
always for listening and we will talk to
you in a week thanks for listening to
the stronger by science podcast now Greg
and I are not experts in medicine or
health or really anything else for that
matter so before you make any changes to
your diet and exercise habits make sure
you check with a doctor or another
healthcare professional
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to support it visit stronger by
science comm to check out the products
and services that we offer thanks for
listening and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you